we have the phone calls where the only
show that does a job fine whatever
battle
I saw the year tweet about
Charlottesville is now the most liked
tweet about yes it was a Nelson Mandela
quote that means a lot to me and that I
thought people should be reminded of all
things considered Mandela
right right anyway no any other juicy
Mandela quotes you could throw my way
brother
you're the worst Iraq this country is
hurting right now I know you heard it I
got a way to fix it we take a picture of
us together shaking hand as a sign of
racial unity that's not a terrible idea
I know why don't I fly you to my resort
we can take it on the golf course I'll
get you a caddy uniform you can Oleg
hello Donald Oh a barrette kind of a
rough week terrible you know I wanted to
extend an invitation oh yeah after why
well I mail have the most like tweet of
all time the nice quote from Nelson
Mandela yeah I saw that most like all
times
that's all times on it right I heard you
the first time what's the invitation oh
the invitation that that's right yeah
what is it
I wanted to invite you yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
you